in the past few weeks we've seen major
disruption in our lives everything is
canceled
everyone is bunkering down due to the
corona virus outbreak because part of
the pattern of disease especially
infectious disease is about a breakdown
of normal order we're seeing this play
out at all levels of reality of course
it is a breakdown of the body as people
get sick and some die
it is a breakdown of society as things
get shut down schools workplace churches
even fragmentation and isolation is
happening at all levels from the
quarantine of people to families the
stopping of travel and the shutdown of
borders but the breakdown is also a
breakdown of meaning which appears as
uncertainty as confusion an incapacity
to know what is true and what would be
panic the measurements and predictions
the planning we usually make in our
daily lives break down as we face
something unknown and unprecedented in
our experience we've seen a lot of crazy
things from the talk of bat soup to the
hoarding of toilet paper but all of it
makes sense when we see this event with
a basic pattern so I want to look at the
symbolism of plagues and epidemics using
our current crisis as a basis but we'll
also look at the basic structures
examine and hopefully make sense of the
very strange example of epidemics in the
Bible and hopefully we can shine a bit
of a light on this moment of uncertainty
and as you already seen I will I have
written down this talk usually I've been
improvising but just to make sure that I
say everything I need to say and that I
don't miss misspeak I've decided to
write this down
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
in order to make sense of what is
happening on a social level why people
are pushing for this or that measure
emphasizing this or that phenomena we
need to understand what is at stake in
terms of narrative and in terms of
cultural struggle the disease is real of
course we don't really know what it is
we know what it is scientifically but we
don't know what it means for us
because it's happening now because we
don't have the hindsight or external
view of what the scope of the disease is
we can't fully understand the danger in
magnifications of the situation the true
danger of the disease itself versus the
danger of the ramifications of
overreacting to the disease we can't
seem to know which one is best and we
know that in excess on both sides can
cause massive damage to our fragile
world so what we're seeing is truly an
acceleration of a breakdown in meaning
and like all breakdowns of meaning the
questions which will arise will be the
most basic ones integrity identity the
relationship between the inside and the
outside the limits we set between the
two and the question of how solid or
flexible those limits should be you see
in the most basic questions the
questions of who we are of what we
should do and how we should relate to
others humans have two basic modes of
being there is what we could call a
connected mode which is the movement
towards the outside the adventure the
openness the diversity the flexibility
the love of change and of novelty
building bridges and all the buzzwords
we've been hearing from one side of the
culture war the other mode of being we
could call the separation mode a move
towards the inside a return to our roots
our identity the select celebration and
participation in our unique quality and
this also involves a level of
differentiation from the outside nation
family religious identities building
walls
all the buzzwords we hear from the other
side of the culture war now what is at
stake in this epidemic is not so much
the disease itself but it's mostly a
fight between two modes of being and
it's very difficult to limit these modes
from manifesting themselves at all
levels of reality and so as all of this
progresses we will see some very strange
swings in discourse we will see very
disturbing contradictions playing out
we'll see positions flip one side to the
other and then smashing against each
other and all of it increasing the
confusion until you might have noticed
the same person who just a week ago was
screeching about being racist and how
horrible it was to ban strangers from
coming to your country you know and how
this is unacceptable is the same one
today who is telling you that you have
to isolate yourself completely socially
but the problem is that as we are
engaging these modes of being it's
impossible it's very difficult for them
not to move from one level of reality to
the next and so just the other day I
watch my own Prime Minister the post
national infinite openness diversity is
our strength Justin Trudeau I watched
him close down our border
now the dirty little secret of an
infectious disease is that it always
comes from the outside doesn't matter
what level you see it if you're always
alone you will not get it infectious
disease you might get some other illness
you know but not an infectious one
you'll get that from someone else a
visitor or stranger in a public place
and this is universally the case and if
you can imagine a normal hierarchy of a
society with the source of your identity
in the middle a form of communion which
binds the elements of your being but
also binds you to your family to your
people to your nation no matter what
level you see it and as we move out from
you we have these different levels of
not you you have friends acquaintances
strangers ultimately you have your
enemies but then you can go in further
and you can identify animals on the very
border of humanity and a traditional
world on the edge of the world you will
find monsters and ultimately chaos and
death so just like on your border you
have your own animal flesh your own body
of flesh in which death will occur and
so two infectious diseases will always
come from different levels of outside
you know let's a visitor a stranger and
ultimately an animal so in the case of
the corona virus it's not surprising
like all other plagues that it came from
somewhere else like China and that there
it is identified as coming from animals
you see for them as well it comes from
the outside and so many infectious
diseases are identified with animals or
vermin you know the wrath of the fleas
of the Black Death the swine flu aviary
flu etc etc and even HIV was rumoured
that it came about because of some
intercourse with monkeys or Apes of
course people will say there is no proof
these are just stories but that is the
point stories help us understand what
something is they click and reveal an
identity even though we don't know even
it's hard to know
whether they're factual or not if
someone had said that aids started from
someone driving their car on a Monday it
would not have wouldn't stick to our
memory it doesn't sound reasonable it
doesn't sound like something that can
exist and so it makes no sense in terms
of narrative and so here is where we get
the story of the bat soup right it's not
that relevant to know whether this is
factually the origin or not maybe it is
maybe it's not but you can't know that
and you have to trust someone who who
will know that I guess but understanding
how it shows us the basic pattern you
know and you can see how it follows the
basic thing especially a bat because
bats are some of the very few monsters
left in the world you know most of the
ancient monsters have been relegated to
the imagination with the advent of
modern science of and let's say the the
obsession with categorization but there
are still some creatures that seem to
inhabit an in-between space and give all
give off what we could call a monstrous
vibe there are of course whales there's
something like the duckbill platypus and
yes of course there are bats that pier
us to us like staying strange
curiosities that are in between or on
the edge of categories
since the end of World War two and in
reaction to the axis and its values the
Western world has emphasized what we can
call a connected mode of being United
Nations the idea of the global village
cosmopolitan internationalism and trade
and culture multicultural states with
mass migration the story of acceptance
of the other has been almost religious
in its tone and as we watch an epidemic
forcing us to isolate ourselves the pain
of changing the narrative is palpable
we're watching European countries
reinstate their borders all of this is
very difficult in a world that was based
on openness and exchange but the reality
is that in a normal world we must always
find a balance between the connected
mode and the separated mode you have to
imagine as a kind of breathing in and
breathing out you always have to do both
you have to breathe in and breathe out
you have to connect and you have to
separate we cannot live in total abandon
of our identities you know as this will
ultimately lead to breakdown to chaos to
conflict and yes it will also lead to
disease for example I've often been
astounded at the naivete of people who
exist that xenophobia is inherently evil
or who want to equate xenophobia with
some kind of racism . this is a sign of
blindness to patterns because everybody
practices xenophobia when we tell our
kids to beware of that stranger with
candy
when we lock the doors of our house or
of our cars you know when we decide not
to chew that piece of gum that we find
under the table and also even just
having borders or armies for the same
reason that you would not be careless
when walking through a dark room it is
normal to have healthy caution towards
things we don't know the problem is
rather a question of balance because you
know we we don't want to completely
isolate ourselves from others this is no
better because it will cause a kind of
asphyxiation
and a weird incestuous self-reference if
you pull too hard on one side you also
risk of creating an excessive side
effect now we see this in the case of
immune systems where if you're too
cautious about foreign out foreign germs
you know if you use all these
disinfectants and you stay really really
really clean and if you and if you're
not in normal contact with others and
with other people's germs you will
develop either develop allergies where
your immune system is not used to being
contact with strange things and so
you'll interpret every single foreign
body as a threat or else you will also
or you'll develop an extreme version of
the disease because you have no
antibodies you haven't developed a
resistance to the effect of strange
things you might get an extreme version
of a disease who for other people would
not be a danger and this is the same on
a social level you can imagine someone
like a recluse who lives in a gated
community all of a sudden they will fear
all strangers and they'll tend to see
them as an immediate threat to their
cohesion as we enter a different mode of
being because of the disease a mode of
isolation and protection it's almost
impossible to avoid the pattern playing
out at different levels of society so as
you avoid touching too many strange
places as you avoid coming close to
others in public places you will it will
also mean that borders will closed that
more encompassing levels of organ
organization will mirror what you're
called to do on a personal level and so
if it if only a week ago those of us on
the connected spectrum those that were
on the connected spectrum of society
were accusing the u.s. president of
being a racist for stopping flights from
China very soon and I guess it's already
the case such cries will stop and the
protectionist separate mode will take
over everyone you see there is an
analogy between the disease itself and
what it causes inside a society just as
the infectious disease breaks down our
body and it's functions just as it
isolates us from others through things
like quarantine
the disease does the same thing in
society as a whole so we have both a
breakdown and fragmentation and a fall
back on these basic identities like
family or self and as we enter this
separate mode the fragility and the
downsides of the connected mode will
become more and more apparent we had
created a world so far-reaching you know
so dependent on the interrelation of
faraway parts on travel and on exchange
and as we have to fall back on ourselves
the entire system will appear that it
might break down the emphasis on these
interrelated you know specialization at
all levels connected by exchange and
transportation has made the entire
system extremely efficient but also
extremely fragile if the connections
break down we will have accelerating
fragmentation a form of decomposition
just as the body's functions break down
in death this will appear clearer and
clearer as the isolation takes its toll
in order to understand epidemic and
infection we also need to understand
purity and looking at how purity works
in Scripture will be a useful thing to
do the thing is that for about a century
or so maybe even more we've seen this
pernicious narrative regarding Scripture
and its purity laws people have tried to
explain the purity laws in the Bible
the laws about hand washing about not
mixing different materials mixing
animals mixing levels of reality they
explain this as some kind of primitive
and clumsy hygiene I've seen the
resurgence of that quite recently this
is a complete upside down understanding
of the world
purity both its advantages and
disadvantages appear in all levels of
reality if you wash your hands to get
rid of what is foreign on your hands
acts of purity also play out at a social
level
imagine for example that Russians would
assign spies and agents to sow discord
in your country to spread rumors or to
influence your elections through this or
that manipulation if that is the case
you want to identify these foreign
influences you want to root them out and
you want them you want to prevent them
from infecting your country and the same
thing can happen at any level of reality
if you discover that a person is sick
with an infectious disease you'll want
to isolate yourself from them it is not
just a question of hiding but one of
borders or just saying goodbye to your
guests at the end of the evening purity
happens at all these levels it even
applies to the very simple act of
distinguished distinguishing between any
category it is an act of purity to
differentiate between a raven and a
writing-desk
understanding how purity is a basic
pattern of reality will help us identify
when it happens and it would also help
in preventing us from letting it
manifest itself in an unwieldly
unconscious matter such incapacity to
see patterns is what brought about the
maddening spectacle in the United States
of that you had these same people who
were screaming about Russian
interference inside the US election you
know simultaneously advocating for open
borders and for non citizen vote and
because people are so unconscious as we
watch the mode of being changed from
this kind of connectivity to
separateness because it is inevitable
that infection comes from the outside
there is a risk of great excess where
there is a risk that we're going to see
scape scapegoating and demonizing which
will bubble up in an unconscious manner
and it might happen in the very same
people that were saying the opposite two
weeks ago because as the mode of being
changes people forget what it was like
to be in the mode of being before but
through all of this there's also a
danger that this state of fragmentation
that someone can use this state of
fragmentation that the
breakdown of all these intermediary
groups like work places like community
groups like churches and businesses all
these intermediary communities you could
say you know could be the basis for
creating even more encompassing systems
of control at a higher level so we have
to be attentive to that as well the most
fascinating aspects of the recent virus
is of course its name the crown virus
seems like a strange appellation and of
course what could point to the
mechanical causes of and and how if you
look at the virus you can see these
protrusions coming out and looks like an
aura or a crown but there is also a
explanation which is related to meaning
i've often pointed out that there is a
strange relationship between death and
glory and even the word crown has the
same origin as the word horn and that
animal horns which are these dead
protrusions at the top of the head and
words are also our weapon are related to
the notion of the crown you could say
one is glory the other is death but more
profoundly it shows us how they are
linked together if we look at the
pattern of infectious disease and we'll
see a little bit about how there is this
weird relationship between glory and
death and now one changes into the other
we can see that in the stories that talk
about infections in the Bible for
example in the book of Samuel the
Philistines who are this great enemy of
Israel in a home of the famous giant
Goliath they steal the Ark of the
Covenant and they bring it into the
their the temple of their God Dagon and
bringing in this foreign object bringing
in something which is sacred and holy
for the Israelites appears rather as a
sacrilege when it is in the temple of
their God the Ark shatters the statue of
Dagon but it also causes the god of the
Israelites to plague the Philistines
with an epidemic the word used to
translate this disease has different
renderings it has been called
hemorrhoids or
tumors in the hidden places and anyway
so they developed these outgrowths where
the Sun don't shine and at the same time
there was a plague of rats or a plague
of mice and already we can see all the
elements I have discussed lining up the
disease comes from the outside the Ark
of the Covenant
coming into a foreign land this plague
is also an excess of flesh and is
related to animals like rats
I mean it's not hard to see the analogy
between this story and the story of the
bubonic plague in the Middle Ages and in
the early modern period this these
plagues these bubonic plague also came
from China and were caused by brats and
manifested themselves through these
large buboes these large kind of
protrusions that were swelling of the
lymph nodes lymph nodes mostly in the
groin and in the armpits and so it's not
even necessary to postulate that these
are the same disease it doesn't matter
but we can notice that symbolism happens
now in order to get rid of the plague
the Philistines had to return the Ark of
the Israelites of course but they also
had to do something else they had to
make golden versions of the hemorrhoids
and of the rats and they had to offer
them up to God and at first glance this
appears as the most insane thing in the
world one of the strangest stories which
is why nobody knows about it because
everybody no one wants to talk about the
story but it is very important to
understand it this story is very similar
as the same pattern as the story of the
bronze serpent you know which Moses made
in the desert the glory of the ark had
become death to the Philistines and now
in order to flip it back and they have
to make a golden version of their death
of their disease they have to make them
into ornaments something akin to a crown
something useless that is in got made of
gold is like an ornament and then they
have to lift up that aspect of the
disease in order to heal themselves from
the plague and of course in terms of
pattern and
with a bit of attention we'll notice
that that is still what we do today
right that's exactly what a vaccine or
an antidote is it is an aspect of a
disease which is understood and which is
used meaningfully and it's taken as a
supplement for those who've watched my
other videos I've talked about the
relationship between the supplement and
the ornament and this can make you
immune from that very disease there is
another plague in the Bible which can
help us understand the pattern as well
King David wants to know how many
warriors he can muster to attack his
enemies and so he does the census he
makes a census on the population this is
seen as a great sin in the story so
biblical scholars will argue over the
technical reason why it was considered a
sin but it doesn't matter so much to us
because in terms of the symbolic
structure we can see how David wanted to
account for everything with the purpose
of attacking his foreign enemy the this
is difficult for some people to
understand but the desire to account for
everything is an overreach of the system
you know order trying to contain
everything and not leaving chaotic
margin not leaving a buffer on the edge
in the biblical law you always have to
leave a remainder for the foreigner you
can you see that in that law about
leaving the corners of your field for
the people who are marginalized and for
the foreigners and we see an example of
exactly this in the in the New Testament
in the Book of Revelations chapter 11
during his vision Saint John receives a
measuring rod from an angel and the
angel tells him to go measure the temple
and but he wants him he says measure the
sanctuary measure the place where the
people worship would do not measure the
outer court for it has been given to the
Gentiles that has been given to the
foreigner it has to remain unaccounted
for unmeasured you need to leave a
fringe on the edge and so david has
tried to completely contain all his
people in order to protect himself form
the foreigner right so you can see it as
someone
who has kept his house completely clean
and fully germ-free for years and the
result of that for David is that he has
given three choices of punishment by God
God says that he has to choose between
three years of famine three months of
falling under the sword of his enemies
or three days of pestilence now the lady
who tried to prevent all contact with
germs for years has made herself weaker
than before you know and all of a sudden
because she isn't exposed to the margin
she will get a much larger version of
the disease who's trying to protect
herself from so David he chose the
pestilence but if you look at the three
choices you can see you know especially
because they're following the rhythm of
threes each of them and related to death
or the three days of Jonah and the Whale
and for Christians ultimately the three
days of Christ's of the tomb and you can
see how these three punishments are
analogically the same they're related to
death just at different scales different
levels of reality
and so having said all of this hopefully
some of the stranger aspects of what is
happening is now clear so why are we
hoarding toilet paper of course once
again we could point to mechanical
reasons toilet paper is bulky so you
know when you put it in your cart other
people will notice this and then think
of getting some and as people the stocks
go down everybody notices and starts to
panic and starts to imitate everybody
else in hoards it fine that's fine but
there's also a an explanation which is
related to meaning and and is completely
coherent as we fall into separation mode
and protection mode intuitively even
though there is no relationship between
the virus and the bathroom in the
scientific manner intuitively we know
that the bathroom is the basic place
where we define what is alive what is
dead what is us what is not us it is the
most basic place where one reaffirms
one's identity through an act of cutting
off of elimination and of cleaning and
that is why the question of the
bathrooms seems to keep coming up in
modern discourse that is why you know it
appeared in all the quit the transgender
debates because it's about identity and
about delimiting or smudging over clear
categories and understanding this
symbolism can help us all I hope keep a
clear head as people you will watch them
you'll see them even in your own
entourage will flip-flop from one side
to the other and their narrative they'll
go from don't be a racist to isolate
yourself from everyone we need to see
clearly what is happening to prevent
unnecessary panic but also unnecessary
naivete but rather navigate a balanced
perception of what is happening around
us so in the end I wish you all a calm
and productive quarantine for those who
are doing that and as we are during Lent
even though the churches have all been
closed and that's pretty crazy if you
think about it when I talk about the
problem
of breaking down intermediary these
these these other communal moments it's
very it's very fascinating but
nonetheless they stop this isolation be
an opportunity for prayer and for
fasting to avoid all the noise of the
crazy world and hopefully to learn to
trust God once again for what is to come
no matter what it is so I hope this
discussion on epidemics was useful there
are a lot of things I could have still
talked about I will probably make
another video on the question of the
golden tumors and the mice and show how
it is a cosmic pattern and I might put
that out as patron video for this month
as you can imagine all my events before
the near future have been canceled and
so I will be giving you more news on
that later thanks to everybody for your
support and stay safe